Winter is finally over and it's time to
pack away the wooly layers and wave
goodbye to winter blues. It's fair to say
that people tend to be far more cheery
and happy during the summer time when
the weather is good rather than the gray
and dreary months of winter but can the
seasons are really affects our mood and
behavior? There is a small subset of the
population who do suffer during the
winter months from a condition known as
Seasonal Affective Disorder. This is
suitably shortened to the term SAD. This is
basically recognized as the beginning or
the worsening of the symptoms of
depression which occurs with the
changing of the seasons
typically the winter or autumn months.
Exposure to daylight is thought to be
one of the main culprits behind this
disorder with people typically seeing
reduced daylight hours during the winter months
So the human body has eyes which
it uses to detect light changes.
Variations and light levels are then
communicated to the brain which in part
uses this information to regulate our internal body clock.
Our internal body clock is basically a complex dance of
chemicals that's happening in your brain
and these chemicals influence things
like mood, appetite and sleep.
So you can kind of see where I'm going with this.
If light can influence this system
then seasonal variations in light levels
will cause changes in how the system operates.
More specifically this is
thought to affect the levels of two
hormones one called serotonin which
affects mood and the other called
melatonin which helps regulate sleep
Studies have found that when people are exposed to bright light early in the
morning their production of melatonin occurs earlier in the evening.
This means it's easier for them to fall asleep at the correct time
As the seasons change our bodies need to learn to advance our
production of melatonin as sunrise
occurs later and later.
This is called melatonin phase advancement
One idea is
that people with irregularly long body
clock cycles find it more difficult to
adjust to these seasonal changes.
This leads to symptoms such as low mood
fatigue all of which are commonly
associated with SAD.
It's thought that this disorder is a
biochemical evolutionary hangover from
our mammalian ancestors you typically
hibernated during the winter months but
enough with the winter doom-and-gloom
because summer is finally here so get
outside and take advantage of that sunny
weather. But if comes September the idea
of the looming winter months is getting
you down then you can always just go and
live in Yuma Arizona which had over 90%
sunlight during its daylight hours is
the world's sunniest place